hello and welcome to the graduate report
my name is so important you should
delete your own name from your memory in
order to make room for mine
jeff klima from new media rockstars here
i'm happy to be sitting down with daniel
grosdich star and host of gradual report
super excited to be talking to the guy
so let's see what he has to say
now daniel how are you doing today i'm
good thank you
very good how you doing now just how the
hell did you get into youtube in the
first place well i graduated from law
school and i was a lawyer for a little
bit and then i wanted to be a comedian
and then uh youtube was just getting
started right around there 2007 2008 and
so i was like oh i could i could put my
comedy on the internet how would you uh
sum up your show the gradual report i
would say it started out as like a
like i kind of wanted to report on news
that was kind of old
you know like this just didn't chernobyl
you know sort of a thing and then it
kind of went to like just my stand-up
comedy being put in like you know vlog
format and now it's evolving into a uh
just whatever is funny now in your
episode you tend to do these kind of
manic voices and crazy characters uh i
guess what i'm asking is were you pretty
manic and crazy growing up you know i
was i would say that bugs bunny was a
huge uh huge influence on my early
comedy life and then uh just you know
growing up with a single parent at home
your second parent would be uh the tv
so i was always i was always like
imitating and doing all kinds of weird
funny
growing up i was i also changed schools
a lot to be funny in class and blah blah
blah you know all that how does a funny
guy like yourself end up in law school
the parents influenced it i basically i
was like hey i want to be a comedian and
they were like wow you should go to
college so i was like all right so i
went to college and then i got out of
college like hey i still want to be a
community like ah well you should get a
trade behind you and then go to law
school and i was like all right and when
i graduated you know i worked as a
lawyer for like maybe two weeks and i
was just like look if i have to do this
the rest of my life i'll just i'd rather
not live i notice you tend to get
shirtless in your videos a lot what's
what's that all about um i started doing
videos without a t-shirt without shirts
so that it would make the videos with
shirts more special
but then i ended up not really selling
t-shirts so it just ended up being naked
all the time anyway now if somebody
didn't know about you per se
what would be one good
video that they could kind of tune into
to watch and just and just see what the
gradual report is all about every video
i put out is funny to me
and that's you know so my every single
one of my videos is hilarious to me
so you know as long as someone's
watching one of them i'm you know look
at the idea what are some of the
channels that you yourself follow rocky
uh he doesn't have too many subscribers
but he's pretty funny has anyone ever
told you that you might just be the
craziest person on the internet yeah
people have said that but they usually
say it in conjunction with like you're
like jim carrey you're crazy or uh or
something like that so i just take it as
a compliment and say awesome what point
in your life did you realize that you
could maybe kind of make a career out of
doing youtube well it's kind of like a
an up and a down like in 2007 they
hadn't really done the partner program
um 2008 like it was looking really like
they were starting to pay people a
little bit
um in 2009 and 2010 i was actually
starting to make enough money to where i
could pay rent but 2012 uh everything
just kind of like took a huge huge
on uh on on independent producers and
whatnot so i'm actually now
transitioning back into working a day
job and supporting my youtube habit
because i'm just not making enough
anymore and you've kind of reached out
uh in your time here to uh some other
youtubers maybe for a little help maybe
for a little exposure a little vice
versa maybe is that true yeah when i was
when i was first starting out philip
defranco and uh sxe phil his show only
had like
like 20 000 subscribers way back in the
day so i like reached out to him to try
and promote me a little and he did shay
carl and i got together on uh on some
stuff we actually met at like youtube
live i think it was like 2009. we're not
like the best friends or anything i mean
they're all like super super busy right
now because they're all super successful
and all that phantasms and uh and i like
went to australia for 18 months so i
kind of like lost touch with everybody
but kasim g had like 9 000 or 8 000
subscribers when i met him and now
they're all like you know multi-million
plus i would say they're all you know
they're all fantastic you know don't get
me wrong but you know you could return a
phone call right
dude
um
it'd be nice i went down to maker just
to kind of like say hi when i got back
into the states
and uh they all had secretaries and they
all had like offices
and i was just like i remember just a
bunch of kids like sitting around your
coffee table like now you got
secretaries and there's like all these
people walking around holding like
notebooks and files and paper and i was
like what is all this nonsense
like we're just making videos but uh now
they're like you know making money on on
it or some i don't know i reached
out to shae to be a part of his um
what's that video called i'm vlogging
here because i actually funny story
known fact i started this thing called d
diario nine on january 1st
and shay actually texted me and he's
like hey dude how's that vlogging every
day thing going and i was like it's
going great you should try it and he's
like oh i think i will and then
shaytards was born but at the time i was
just like some startup comic you know
documenting his life whereas jay had
like his whole array colorful family to
like draw from so it's just way more
interesting anyway and you say you're
kind of on a you're kind of on a down
slope right now so
do you feel that there is a shelf life
to youtube users and creators there
certainly is a shelf life to being a
popular youtube star because people
grow up and they get over you and they
move on and that's perfectly normal and
perfectly healthy and then maybe if
you're lucky they'll come back and be
like oh i remember when i was a kid and
i used to really watch the transformers
you know and so like you know the
gradual report has that little space and
time in that in that person's life um
and maybe they come back to it and go oh
yeah you're still doing it great my
views are like
you know 14 15 000 uh a new episode now
where they used to be like in the 60 to
70 000
um views and then if it was like
particularly funny it would hit a
hundred or two hundred thousand but now
it's like i don't know it's like a tenth
of what it was and that that's that's a
product of like a lot of things all i
can do is is keep making videos that are
funny to me
and putting it out there and then it's
it's like each video could be the next
you know the next hilarious whatever
like uh i'm just waiting for that one
breakout idea that kind of grips the
nation and is it the right place at the
right time with the right you know all
kinds of stuff if you just if you're
able to keep the dream going and keep
fighting and keep putting videos up then
um we'll see
i'm certainly going to keep trying so
yeah you have any sage advice for future
youtubers just do what you love and then
get it out to as many people as you can
because then at least you're doing what
you love even if it doesn't work out
you're like yeah whatever i had a lot of
fun doing it but if it's not fun then
you know i can find something else that
is more fun
building planes or
kites or
you know whatever i don't know that's
what i think is fun so that's what i do
now danny i just wanted to thank you for
taking the time to sit down and do this
crazy chat thing with us and we really
appreciate it here at nmr thanks for
thanks for thinking i'm important enough
to talk to i appreciate it
you